let's turn our attention now to the
Press preview which is a first look at
what is on the front pages as they
arrive and in the next half hour or so
we'll be having a look at what's making
a headlines with The Observers Chief
leader writer Sonia soda and the
telegraphs associate editor for politics
Christopher hope good to have you both
on uh well let's start shall we we're
having a bit of a rundown of what is on
at some of those front pages shall we
the mirror pictures the Queen's
grandchildren standing vigil around her
coffin their headline Granny's guard of
Honor
the Sunday people cause the gesture a
vigil of love
the Sunday Telegraph has the simple
headline
together for granny
let's have a look at the Sunday Times
now showing a cluster of mourners
greeting Prince William the Sunday Times
describes the lengthy cues to
Westminster Hall as as people's
pilgrimage
and the Sunday Express has word of a
campaign to establish a permanent bank
holiday in Her Majesty's honor
and while the Observer covers today's
Royal events their main concern is
previewing a challenging week ahead for
the new prime minister Liz truss
a quick reminder that if you just scan
the QR code that you can see on screen
right now during the program then you
can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch the
three of us uh chew over what they have
so welcome once again to Sonia soda and
Christopher hope uh good to have you
with us unsurprisingly most of the
newspapers focusing on that incredibly
moving grandchildren vigil the Sunday
Mirror a Granny's guard of honor their
title absolutely and I actually had to
watch it this evening
um on catch up but I found it so moving
actually to see the eight grandchildren
including princess William and Harry
come in and do their 15-minute guard of
Honor around the Queen's coffin I think
it was a very moving site obviously
you're going to be feeling very
emotional I think if any of us thinks
about what it would be like to stand
vigil around the coffin of a parent or a
grandparent very difficult to do and not
to show emotion and um a couple of the
greens Queen's grandchildren are
obviously very young 18 and 14 and they
took part in this as well so there were
a bit there were question marks earlier
in the week I think about whether this
was going to happen and the palace was
always clear but it's up to the Queen's
grandchildren whether they want to do it
themselves and they decided the eight of
them together that it was a tribute that
they wanted to pay but I think it was
just it was quite difficult to watch
actually
um it's that kind of clash of the
personal and the private and the very
public gays or the people in the hall
but also of course on TV screens and on
the internet everywhere and that
connection that we all feel we have with
the queen few of us have meta but he's
all seen her we've seen our stamps and
money but I mean just watching the the
feed of everyone walking it's almost
like a like a religious experience they
they queue I was in the queue tonight
with my daughter and you go we will have
our ticket to go in yet but you you
queue it and you go up the stairs and
then you end this this rays of lights
and there's this coffins are having been
in the hall to watch it it's like a
moving portrait I mean it's like like a
big painting so the colors are so clear
aren't they and so well lit
um and it just feels deeply emotional
and a few things about the images on
this front page here you see Prince
Harry there wearing his uniform that
also by professional person of the king
um also I think granny is probably
spelled wrong with the royal family they
spell it with an ie at the end which I
don't understand all that in the um the
statement from Princess Beatrice and
Eugenie today
um
and just talking about the the personal
experience of it I think what we really
felt wasn't it that these are eight
grandchildren who obviously had a very
personal relationship with their granny
the woman they call Granny um Eugenie
and Beatrice talking about picking
raspberries with her or you know going
for tea at her house
yeah that's right but then at the same
time as you said Sophie she was also
their Queen and for princess William and
Harry who served in the armed forces uh
you know she was their sort of
commander-in-chief as well as it were so
um I I think it's you know I think it
was very as I said I think it was very
moving to watch I think it's quite
difficult to think about having to do
something like that yourself with the
eyes of the Nation on you not just the
mourners filing past but you know that
so many people will have been tuning in
to sort of watch it on TV and for me
actually it was kind of a mixed feeling
because I wanted to see it but at the
same time you sort of feel like you're
intruding almost on people's private
grief as well I felt I felt the same
actually about
um the Queen's children but perhaps even
more so with the grandchildren
particularly given two of them are so
young and the future is them though
those those images you have there are
amazing and there's eight of them and
you know she's gone right so the Duke
van was gone Queen's gone it's up to you
guys now that's a big moment I mean
we're starting just over the road from
here aren't we tomorrow with this
massive uh
um meeting of the new king with all of
all the Joe Biden all the world leaders
like 100 State visits in a day uh
tomorrow here outside your studio here
um and it's all the these These are
eight eight uh people these you know
young people remember other future the
monarchy
much time for for private grief let's
have a look at the front page for the
Sunday people show with vigil of love
and you you're just seeing there William
and Harry as standing next to each other
and just to pick up on a point that you
were making before about Harry wearing
his uniform but the first time that's
happened since 2020 I think yeah and I
think it was you know the right decision
because I think it would have been very
difficult I think everyone would have
been commenting on it if he had he has
hadn't been in his military uniform and
I think the thing you've got to remember
is that however you feel about um Prince
Harry he served two active tour of
Duties um in Afghanistan so I think to
not let him wear his uniform for this
occasion I I just don't think it would
have been right actually so um I think
it was it was fitting
um that King Charles allowed him to do
so and it's nice to see the two brothers
together as well yeah yeah they're not
the same picture there Sophie they're
different things together they are they
are together yeah they're all together I
mean I to me this puts holes of Megan
um Harry drama into some kind of context
I mean the sheer weight of the
importance of the monarchy outside the
studio you've got Scouts on the streets
you've got m m z Armed Forces giving out
rugs in the queue giving you a chair I
mean it feels amazingly really proud to
be British and I think it puts a soap
opera of of the Harry Megan show into
some kind of context in many ways it's
just like any family isn't it people
fall out they're a sort of drama and
then actually families do sort of tend
to come together and put differences
aside at a time like this let's hope it
looks like they can they can keep
talking and they send a telegrapher scan
using that word as you were saying
together so I guess that is the hope to
kind of bring the family together
together for granny their headline
another misspelling of quantity
now sorry viewers I shouldn't have
pointed out
but they talk about the display of
composure and family bonds from the
grandchildren of Queen Elizabeth II at
the vigil it has been quite moving
hasn't it the whole of the last few days
and the individuals in particular I
found it surprisingly moving actually
just because I think it is this very
public display of controlled emotion
which is what the royal family are quite
known for but at the same time you know
what must be going on in all of their
heads because you know that for example
the grandchildren where as you say very
very close to the queen lots of very
personal memories so it is that dual
thing of you know I sort of think about
how I felt uh my own grandparents
funeral I mean I was not as composed as
that let's put it like that
um
and also the people who didn't even know
her as well I think it's worth just kind
of reflecting on on the Queue at the
people who have queued up for I think
that like 12 hours or more I just think
it's amazing I mean when I first heard
that
um you know that the authorities were
allowing for people to queue for 24
hours at a time they're expecting people
to be spending doing overnight shifts in
the queue I sort of did things really is
that really going to happen but I mean
it really sort of has come to pass and
I've been really surprised at just how
caught up in it I've been as an observer
here we're British and actually even
just watching the lying in state on BBC
Parliament um I've been doing some of
that and watching people
use the wallpaper I've moved you know
when you hear the tap tap tap of the
change of the watch every 20 minutes
it's on again so you know it's all there
I mean it begin to indicue tonight for
an hour an hour or two it was it's so
happy
um it's Jolly you've been given rugs and
chairs and water every five minutes and
it is um it's definitely become its own
phenomenon hasn't it it was quite hard
when the accessibility we couldn't find
the beginning so we used to behind a few
people no working with something else so
there aren't many sub cues in the queue
and you mentioned you went with your
daughter it's been really lovely to me
to see the number of young people in the
queue as well they want to do it I mean
they see it as something which and you
know I think it's just it is it is part
of it is definitely cueing to see they
see the Queen's body of course and that
and that a special moment in Westminster
Hall that so many people want to get
right let's have a quick look at the
front page of the Sunday Times the
people's pilgrimage they're describing
it and really I mean these are the
pictures that you know we were sort of
describing earlier aren't we they're
kind of camaraderie at the queue and
look at these guys these were the lucky
ones who got to meet uh Prince Williams
absolutely and I think the stories you
hear about the friendships that are
being formed it's quite extraordinary so
I know people who've stood in in the
queue for sort of 12 hours at a time and
they describe the people that they've
met in their Queue at by the end of it
is their key family they've all got
photos of them all together which I
think is I think I don't think people
thought they were doing this for the
experience of queuing as well as the
experience of paying respects but I
suspect that a lot of people are coming
out of it feeling a bit like it is a
pilgrimage and it's that experience the
sort of that communal experience of
waiting in some quite tough conditions
you know it's not exactly warm it's
quite difficult physically to be
standing for that long there's lots of
people who are standing in that queue
for whom it's not an easy thing to do
you know they may be
um uh you know they may have mobility
issues they'll be slightly older and
they're still doing it and I think
people are kind of
um sort of experiencing that for what it
is
um in a way that perhaps many of us
wouldn't have predicted days you would
do a pilgrimage to Canterbury from Saint
Albans for example the West Jordan was
martyred and you you'd go to see the
altar now you queue for 12 hours from um
from the tower bridge now what's the
difference between the queen
um someone I saw something today say
that if John Lewis hasn't worked out
what his Christmas advert is it's going
to be a couple who met in the queue
I saw a film of someone and yeah
yeah well well I I there's a there's two
young people quite good looking you know
maybe in their 20s
I was actually joking though a couple of
days ago to friends that if there isn't
a q marriage by the end of sort of five
days of this experience we're doing
something wrong and and again I mean
it's sort of it I think in some ways
it's nice to be able to joke about it
because this is such a sort of momentous
occasion where there's a lot of grief
and I think it's nice to be able to find
Joy the joy of the queue experience is
something this photo on the front page
of Prince William reach into the crowd
there of course post covered that's okay
but reach into the crowd shaking hands
and they the The Prince and Prince of
Wales but a really nice no title Twitter
saying thank you this means so much
because this is like showing the royal
family there was a lot of love for you
guys and we're all behind you and that
you need to have that almost you know
checked checked again yeah it is it is
quite right and also the point that you
were making Sondra about we do need a
bit of joy in our lives don't we the
news has felt so depressing recently
that at the queue there's something
quite life-affirming about it yeah
lamb who's a legendary war reporter
um not used to produce
uplifting stories here but the but she
talks how this in in this excellent
color piece on the front page so many
times how it's a polite convivial and
stoic Group which really sums up the
entire country yeah it does
inside shall we we can just dip inside
the express now and have a look at at
the express they're talking about some
of the dignitaries are they
that's right so
um I think this will probably be an
occasion where we see the greatest
number of world leaders all come
together to sort of Mark the queen
um the Queen's life and in tribute to
her
um but obviously you can imagine it's
quite the logistical challenge with this
number of world leaders coming in and so
there's been all sorts of Arrangements
um you know for example many world
leaders are not going to be able to sort
of take their own transport to the
funeral they will be coming in on
coaches which I or minibuses which I
assume not many of them are accustomed
to
um but some of them are already in the
country we've already seen Jacinda are
done I think the prime minister of New
Zealand who was the first person to the
first world leader to go and pay her
respects to the queen in Westminster
Hall but Justin Trudeau is now in the UK
some other world leaders
um I think the King has already hosted
some at Buckingham Palace so it really
is going to be a case of world leaders
descending on London
the hard turn is important because she
thinks that New Zealand will drop the
monarchy in her lifetime so here's the
opportunity to show that the best of the
of the monarchy in this country and why
it matters and why maybe having someone
who's above politics can't be relaxed
every five or five years or so it's
quite it's quite a good model to follow
I mean and I think that's an example of
showing this it's
not we were talking earlier about the
the how difficult it must be for the
Royals with this private grief and then
suddenly thrust into their public duties
and none more so than the new king
obviously and who is grieving for his
mother and yet today he's meeting
leaders of the Commonwealth realm some
of them who we know are thinking about
potential referendums on the coming
Republicans degree of acceptance I mean
King Prince of Wales now King Charles
was out in Barbados last November
overseeing the becoming a republic no
problems the feeling was no problems
here is up to you and we will facilitate
it if that's what you want which
probably is
yeah yeah yeah
um yeah and but as you say as well the
logistical challenge with it as well
must be and the security I mean the
number of pilly I think it's going to be
the greatest number of police possibly
ever in London for the day of the
funeral the security will be um yeah the
security Arrangements will it will have
been obviously years in the planning
well article here by market generally in
in the express so they've run out of
motorbike Riders because so many they've
run out of like outriders they're
borrowing out Riders from other parts of
the country well it's unusual I mean
it's the world's biggest park and ride
that's great you've got to pull up and
then just get into the back of a coach
yeah this is the fall on British
experience I guess it does also
illustrate the soft power of the
monarchy I mean there's not many moments
when you get at this level of world
leaders I think it's around 100 heads of
states or presidents from across the
world you know Joe Biden president of
America uh jetting in and he will get to
take his own transport yes he's been
allowed the Beast is going to make its
way to Westminster yes
and there'll be others too I mean macros
coming she's stupid she is the most
famous woman in the world can we agree
on that the queen was
I think so
yeah and she touched I mean when you
know what we saw less recently was an
amazing um documentary called Queen
Elizabeth II on the BBC hospital last
night back in 94 and the access she gave
and and that's when she really was in
her prime it was extraordinary she
certainly think she's the most respected
British figure internationally but
modern British figure
um I'm interested to know your thoughts
that given that that she was perhaps the
most famous woman in the world do you
agree with the Sunday of Express which
is calling on MPS to in States an annual
celebration honor our Queen with ER day
okay so first of all when
so when would be probably in the Autumn
or winter because we have nothing after
the August 31st before Christmas so you
could do a kind of but then have it what
you know end up being in November but
there's a big cost to this it's of a
billion pounds of lost productivity it
can mean it tips tips can't hit the
economy into recession if it's marginal
on growth there are other ideas too
um there's the Royal Britannia that
should be recommissioned
just a credit there but not a fair one
because it's a telegraph campaign
um it could be called raw yacht
Elizabeth there's also a fourth Clinton
Trafalgar Square empty perhaps the the
former the late queen with the Duke of
Edinburgh or maybe the maybe the queen
on her Burmese horse
they're all sorts of ideas yeah
I think well I
um I'm always in favor of the next I've
always been in favor of an extra bank
holiday I think it's actually
um something good um
there is a cost but we actually we by
International standards if you look at a
country like France we don't actually
have that many bank holidays as you say
Chris they're not that well spread out
um they can really help kind of bacon
Hollow daily for people who don't get as
much holiday because they're on casual
contracts for example working zero hours
contracts so
um I I never think an extra bank holiday
is a bad thing in November you need a
bit of cheering after November it'll be
like it's like Thanksgiving it'll kick
off Christmas won't it it'll book end
Christmas probably yeah there you go
well it feels like we're relatively in
favor you you're maybe
you're okay is important right let's
turn to The Observer now shall we and
the main picture on the Observer is the
grandchildren's vigil but the story is
about the bruising return in the words
of the Observer that trusts Liz truss
the Prime Minister faces after the
funeral well I'm really glad I mean
obviously The Observers my paper so I'm
biased but I'm really glad that there's
a bit of a look ahead to the Politics as
well as this you know featuring this
very important national moment on the
front and um you know the the period of
national mourning will come to an end
this week after the funeral it will mean
a return to politics we've got Liz trust
flying off to New York to the um and
we've got this huge question still
overhanging us of course it has sort of
been a bit subdued political debate as
you would expect over the last few days
but um before the queen uh passed away
we have this big conversation about what
is the government going to do about
burgeoning energy bills and we were
starting to get some briefing about what
the pack kids might look like for
individual households but there was very
very little detail about what there
might be for businesses on the one hand
and public services like schools and
hospitals and the other and you've still
got businesses I mean obviously we are
in this period of national mourning but
businesses are still getting these
letters from energy companies warning
them about how much their bills will be
going up to next month if they don't get
help from the government and we're
talking about lots of small businesses
in the community pubs cafes have been
there for decades who simply I mean this
is more serious than covert for many of
them they're simply not going to be able
to pay the bills if the government
doesn't step in and help and you know
this is a problem that has been coming
down the track for months the
government's known about it obviously
there's been a lot of changes in our
politics we've got a new prime minister
but to leave businesses hanging I think
has been very very it's been
Unforgivable
well yes there'll be a lot of that I
mean I think also you know you get the
U.N general assembly for Liz truss
Tuesday Wednesday back Thursday Friday
the mini budget so we're going to revert
those she'll be reversing the National
Insurance increase
um not going ahead with increasing
corporation tax 25 from 19 maybe take a
penny off income tax maybe something on
business rates that's because that's 30
billion already plus more
and then we're going into the party
competencies now they these MPS are
barely sat in Parliament since so the
end of the end of July absolutely I've
been there for five days five days so
far which one of them willawan was
giving um
tributed to the to the queen so it does
I think there's an increasing in our in
our letters page in the telegraph we're
seeing a lot of people saying you know
when are they going back to work there's
a lot on all the issues you raise there
and they've been all right to chat about
them in the sky Studio but they should
be taught right in parts of parliament
more they're not being at all it is
quite extraordinary isn't it that this
huge spending package was announced 150
billion some people are saying well
how'd you know that well
this is a speculation that's a low low
ball number and yet there's been as you
say the scrutiny of it has been almost
non-existent because
um of the of what's obviously happened
two and a half thousand pound which is
the cap is the average for households
yeah it can be a lot more so I'm sorry
my teenagers turn the lights off it's
not an average number you're not going
to not like a free agency it's not just
a cat for everybody yeah at that at that
level uh just very quickly the Sunday
Times have got a bit of a glimpse on to
what we might be able to expect when
everything does start kicking back into
motion uh the new uh Chancellor to cut
red tape to rip up the rules in a gamble
to get Britain booming well I think this
is a what we are seeing right now in
real time is a massive punt on on Tory
right-wing policies working because if
it comes off case arm is in some trouble
the next election there's trust wins if
it doesn't come off I think you bury
Torio geology for a day for a generation
and this is this is this is going to be
the big ideological fight really which
is that is the best way to boost growth
by spending and supporting people
through a massive crisis or is it by
doing very expensive tax cuts and coming
back on regulation including things like
Environmental Protection which is what
this story is talking about and
personally I'm skeptical I would say
this I work for Center left paper but
I'm skeptical that deregulation is a way
to boost growth when you're in the kind
of current economic quagwise whatever
side of the argument you're on it's the
gamble because we're going to find out
what Bruce going to be
sure it won't be it'll be one or the
other and so it was quite clear for us
as Jonas watching it yeah it'd be a
really fascinating to see and of course
we're expecting that statement the mini
budget from the new Chancellor quanta on
Friday correct yeah
Debbie
it coming up on that thank you both uh
very much for being with us tonight